[Music]
hello and Welcome to our series a wolf
in sheep's clothing I'm your host
blessings win today we introduce a young
woman who abandoned her Christian
upbringing to pursue wiah and Eastern
meditation despite being a close family
member of three abn's founders she
became quick prey to New Age
spiritualism join us as we hear Haley
Wolf's compelling testimony on the
doorways into the new age hi Haley thank
you so much for for being here today
thank you for having me it's such a
pleasure we want to know a little bit
about your faith upbringing yeah so I
was raised in the Seventh Day Adventist
Church went to a Christian School went
to church every
Sabbath um very Christian
background right sounds like you're
checking all the boxes there so did you
find that having a uh grandfather such
as Danny Shelton did it influence you
did you find find that helpful yeah um
there was a lot of experiences I got to
have just fantastic experiences um I got
to travel a lot with him as a kid watch
him
evangelize um really see how Ministry
Works um I had a lot of good
opportunities with all of that um met a
lot of great Christians Haley walk us
through your journey as you stepped away
from
Christianity yeah so um as I was growing
up like I mentioned and surrounded by
lots of Christian people but um in my
teen years I started noticing a lot of
these Christians that I knew were very
hypocritical with a lot of things they
would say you know hey we need to live
these certain ways but they really
weren't walking the ways that they were
speaking of and um I it concerned me um
because I was afraid that is this what
happens to people as they get older you
know um you don't follow these really
great practices you know that we learn
from the Bible um does that mean that
these practices are too hard to follow
right I can definitely um relate to this
I can remember feeling the same way and
perplexed at times but we must remember
that we can't legitimize Christ by
followers of Christ it's the other way
around right absolutely is the one that
justifies sanctifies and glorifies us so
did you find yourself dabbling in things
that you knew were
prohibitive yes so for me it actually
started um with questions of is the
Bible accurate are we sure about this I
I heard some arguments from atheists
that I thought were very
compelling and because of that uh I feel
like I was more inclined to dabble in
other things because you know wasn't so
sure that hey you know maybe like
spirits and things like that don't
actually exist and why is it people
would believe in stuff like Witchcraft
and I think that was a big reason I
started deciding to dabble was just
experimenting you know to see like well
is this real you know why are there
people who call themselves witches and I
ended up trying out a few different
things um you know I went to the
library uh started reading on different
kinds of Witchcraft wiah appealed to me
specifically because they say that you
know you only practice good magic um
light things no spells that will harm
people and so as I was looking into that
um I learned you know what materials you
would need how to do spell work I
dabbled with things like candle magic um
I bought tarot cards um and really
though my experience was interesting
because um I was trying to approach it
with the scientific method right you
know it has to work again and again
before I can decide that this is real
and um I actually found a lot of the
stuff didn't really work for me um like
the tarot cards at first uh you know I
wasn't really getting like answers that
weren't just really vague uh the candle
magic there was a lot of that I feel
like it could have just been a
coincidence um yeah uh the things that
actually started working for me though
um were things like I started practice
automatic
writing um so that is when they tell you
you know okay just like clear your mind
don't plan on saying any particular
things maybe ask a question and just let
the pen go over the paper and I wrote
things that didn't sound like me but
they were very good answers and if there
were questions about like you know how
to do a certain thing or where I would
be at a certain point it actually seemed
very
accurate um and so just seeing some of
those results started to get me a little
bit more interested like well maybe
there's some kinds of magic that work
for some people and other ones that
don't so did you ever find yourself
recalling scripture you know there are
several war warnings within Exodus you
know throughout the whole Bible Isaiah
you know that says that you have to try
the spirits and that we should stay away
from divination was any of that coming
to your mind or was this experience so
powerful that it took you in the
complete opposite direction well at the
at the time when I started actually
practicing these things um I was calling
myself an atheist because I really just
didn't believe in the Bible or God and
um it's funny looking back on that now
because you know well if I thought there
could be Spirits maybe that was you know
not quite atheism right but um my
atheism made me brave enough to just try
a lot of different things like that um
the Bible verses I mean like I heard in
the back of my head head you know like
like this is not you know okay right but
that's I I just attributed that to oh
well you know I it's because I was
always told that it's drilled into my
head but it could just be like that's
just what they said doesn't make it true
right there is an appearance that being
uh versed in the Bible is a is a source
of uh brainwashing yeah and you know the
thing that kind of makes me feel like we
had similar experiences is this whole
clear your mind right and what we don't
understand is that when we empty our
mind we allow ourselves to become a
vessel for something else that doesn't
necessarily have the best interest um
did you find yourself uh dabbling Say in
any kind of physical um types of of
worship so yes um in wiah because I was
trying to follow all the rules make sure
you know I really gave it a chance an um
there was a lot of books that said you
need to build altars and you know you
can choose gods or goddesses from
different pantheons or you can just go
with the general there's the goddess and
then the horned god let's talk a little
bit more about that who is the horn God
so the horned god um there was a lot of
there were a lot of interpretations on
that um people would him to the sun god
um you would see sometimes statues
people would use bamet um which you see
a lot in like Satanism like a goat thing
with the horns um and um but when I was
looking at it instead of looking into
all of his lore or anything like that
you know I just figured okay we'll we'll
generalize it and say um he represents
masculine energy and the goddess
represents feminine energy and you can
represent them by the Sun and the Moon
that's really interesting because in
yoga which is something that I became
pretty versed in um and even lived
abroad you know uh went to an asham and
studied this that there's a parallel I
see where they too have a sun and a moon
energy and um the whole point of it is
to allow yourself to be able to awaken
the serpent at the base of the spine and
so this is known as Kundalini energy so
there's a similarity between
and uh like a Common Thread in yoga
Eastern mysticism yeah I actually found
um that it was my dabbling and beliefs
that I ended up developing through wi
that allowed me to see um like the yogic
spirituality more clearly um because I
already understood things like the
clearing of the mind I already
understood um the different energies
they talk
about um things like chakra work and all
of those things they have in a lot of
yoga but it's also part of a lot of
Witchcraft too so it was almost like the
wiah practices prepared me for yoga yeah
so you spent time studying yoga as well
is that correct yes yes talk about that
a little bit I went to school for yoga
um how I got into it was I had heard
that yoga
was a really good practice to like
destress and that it's an easy exercise
right and so I remember I went online
tried to watch some videos in practice
and I found okay yeah it's slowing me
down it's it's easy enough and so I
started attending an actual class and I
was a regular um I kept going because I
found that um my mind was clearing up
and I was enjoying the practice and the
yoga instructor came up to me um after
one practice and asked me hey have you
ever thought of becoming a yoga
instructor you're really good at this
and I was looking into what kind of
career I might want to do at the time
and I I never thought to do yoga like
that but I really enjoyed it so I
thought maybe yeah so I looked up school
around um I found a whole College just
for yoga and um I had a lot of
experiences going through that um uh
originally I got into it thinking that I
was going to be learning a lot of
anatomy and
physiology you know the stretches
exercising those kinds of things but um
as time went by in the classes it
started transitioning to something much
more spirit spiritual now when I walked
in there were already things like you
know
statues um there was Buddha and Krishna
and things like that but to me at the
time they were just statues and I didn't
really think anything of it I had a lot
of um Wick and understanding of the
world at the time but I still was very
agnostic about a lot of things um so I
didn't really believe in those Gods but
I did start believing in energies
energies yeah which um is a word that
some people use uh a safe word almost
rather than saying things like
Spirits they say energies so I just want
to backtrack a little because you said
something that I thought was really key
yeah you know uh the way that that yoga
is marketed here it's you know innocuous
with uh like exercise yes do you feel
that yoga is exercise absolutely not no
and how would you say it differs from
exercise well um after I was finished um
graduating from The Yoga College I
actually also um went into training to
be a personal trainer with like regular
lifting weights cardio that kind of
exercise and it is very different um you
have a totally different mindset when
you're doing it um I feel like yoga is
very much a spiritual practice um
there's a lot of exercises you can do
and stretches you can do but in the
context of yoga um there there's a
different goal the goal isn't Just
Fitness or
flexibility um the goal is what they
call Oneness and yoking yeah yoking
becoming one with everything around you
and more specifically becoming one and
yolked with brah BR yeah uh and um and
Brahman for those of of you at home who
don't know who he is he is basically the
head God in the pantheon right and um
that was a concept that at first you
know because I wasn't so sure how I felt
about gods and things like that um I
wasn't really so into that idea but as I
started doing the practices more they
have breathing practices payama correct
yes so controlled
breathing um meditation classes yoga the
movements in the exercise um is actually
they would always say this is a moving
meditation that's right yes and there
there in lies the difference yes and the
thing that I learned that I you know
didn't actually realize until after I
had you know discovered the the darkness
of yoga was that the actual point of
yoga is to exhaust the body so that the
mind can then be emptied and you know
the the unification of the deity that
you're worshiping could then come into
you yeah and that each exercise is
actually supposed to bring death to a
different part of the body so the whole
goal is death and Union with this
serpent Spirit yeah and a lot of people
don't even know that um a lot of these
poses some classes they'll use the
original names but a lot of them we have
English terms for them like say the
warrior 1 2 and three no matter what
yoga class you're going to they always
have the warrior one two and three in it
right um but a lot of people don't know
you're reenacting a story that's right
and um the original name for that is um
ver so ASA is like the pose and ver
badros is actually a God and he was a
murderous God and um you're acting out a
very graphic killing um scene yeah and
that a lot of people aren't aware of
that there's actually um a lot of things
with that like for example so um when
you're learning to teach
yoga um you have to do poses in certain
sequences um like these kind of poses
and then these kind um so you have to
teach it a certain way and um
what what's happening here though is a
lot of that even has to do with um like
chakra energy kind of work they're
trying to get your your body and your
mind in certain states by doing this
that's right whereas say um in regular
exercise you know obviously you're not
doing that right but we can take um so a
lot of people who do normal exercise
they know about um plank right um and
you see that exact same form in yoga but
there is a difference and um the
difference is when you're doing it in
yoga um you're flowing from one thing to
the next and you're using that to push
different energies or maybe even tell
one of those stories get into a certain
position to worship right it links all
the myth mythological stories yes yes
where whereas if you're just doing that
like you know like a normal ab exercise
I mean it's okay you know um there's no
spiritualism involved in that right so
you find yourself at this Yoga College M
and and at this point are you starting
to decide you know there's truth in this
you know I need to go deeper yeah so um
it's interesting how it worked for me
I've always been such a skeptic and so
um going there you know I saw um most of
the people I went to school with were
actually Christians
um and there were some other like dsts
and Buddhists right um and I noticed the
as the classes went on the months went
by um a lot of say even my Christian
friends they started practicing
Christianity in a very Hindu way right
and they started seeing
Jesus as oh well you know he has this
thing called Christ
Consciousness and you know like um can
all be like Gods you know and um for me
you know I saw this happening and but I
also saw um how they were feeling um and
I noticed like wow you know like they
seem happier they seem healthier um and
so I started getting interested a little
bit more interested in the spiritual
side just because I was looking for
something to calm myself down with as
well um um but it wasn't until after I
already graduated Yoga College um I
started feeling like okay you know like
I need to like really make sure I'm the
best I can possibly be if I'm going to
teach people and so I can't just be
really good at the poses you know I
really got to deep um dig deep down into
say like there's writings like the yoga
sutras get better at meditation and
that's so key because it's not just
exercise right they give you a pose and
you want to be able to perfect it you
see the other people practicing with you
and they can get the pose to a a degree
that seems impossible so then you go to
your yoga teacher and you say hey what's
up with that how come she can do that
and I can't and before you know it
you're in the books studying this stuff
yep yep and see originally I just got
into it thinking it was just exercise I
would be learning but absolutely not if
you're going to do it right you know um
you can't avoid the spiritualism in it
so you're deep in yoga you're deep in in
wiah how did you find yourself moving
out and back to your roots so what
happened um is I actually got really
really deep into yoga um
I um my grandmother um mentioned to me
about like hey you know this is actually
a dangerous part this is the first time
I'm hearing that like this is actually a
dangerous practice you know it could be
leading you into all sorts of things and
when she said that um I decided I need
to look more into this what am I missing
from yoga and actually what ended up
happening is as I was discovering oh
there's a lot more I started getting
into the like real like Hindu vant which
is like Hindu scriptures to really
understand and I realized wow there is
so much more to yoga like this is really
a branch of uh the Hindu
religion and um so you know she may have
thought at the time like uhoh because I
started actually getting more into it
when I found that out and before you
know it uh I was in a point a mind like
a completely different state of mind
where um I felt like wow I'm actually
believing this now like I'm believing
because I did the meditation I did the
yoga poses and it really really
influenced me and I was getting yeah um
just so confused about like well how
could anyone believe anything other than
yeah you know like because there's some
things that are starting to manifest and
materialize yeah and the Vantas are
actually very dangerous because you
start to get into the kind of the
chemical uh portions that people don't
know
about the of sha yeah talk about that a
little bit originally when I started
meditating I was practicing to clear my
mind but now that I understood what the
point of that was I took it to the next
step okay I need to become one with
Brahman which to me yeah I was I from
what I understood an
impersonal living being that is in
everything we're all right brahen it's
in the table it's in in the shoe you
wear it's in the fruit you eat God is
all right yep and I started really
feeling that something that I actually
believe influenced me even more with
that um is during a lot of these
meditations to connect better um I would
get high on marijuana and this is one of
the Blessed gifts from Shiva who is a
basically an avatar of Brahman he's the
god of this particular type of
meditation so you find yourself doing
weed now you're deeper in your practice
even though you know you're wonderful
grandmother has said hey hey hey you
know this is dangerous get out how did
you finally find your way out well in
the end um I believe I always tell
people my story is a rescue story
because in my head there was not a
person I could talk to who would ever
convince me otherwise at this point I
thought everyone El was confused mhm
they weren't enlightened they weren't
awake enough um and I went outside and I
sat down to
meditate and I decided you know I I was
thinking about as I was looking at
nature you know I'm I made this
interesting that because you know if I'm
the Creator right right I made this it
sounded weird you know it sounded kind
of strange
but um I was I was looking how beautiful
everything was and that's when I
started getting this familiar
feeling um it was warm and of love and I
started recognizing as this is what I
would feel when I was praying to God as
a child the Christian God and I I just
immediately felt you know this uh this
pull in me to ask God one more time last
chance God did you really make this or
is that blind thinking mhm but he
actually answered me and it was it was
such a crazy experience and he showed me
I made all of this this was love and
incredible that was just the start
because as soon as he gave me that I
knew I had to go straight to the Bible I
had to go straight back into well if
that was God I need to like learn
correctly about him because in new age
in Hinduism they take Bible verses out
of context flip them around and put you
in the place of God exactly but he's so
merciful that even in your act of
apostasy that he could still reach you
so that gives us the knowledge that no
matter how far gone you are that God has
mercy and forgiveness and he has an
outreached hand to you and will take you
back it's so beautiful because I didn't
do anything to deserve that I kept
rejecting him and running away but he
kept trying for me he he I had been so
far and he was the one who pulled me
right out of it and there are thousands
probably even millions of people in your
same shoes would you make an appeal to
people who might be in your same
predicament
absolutely I think the biggest thing
that I could tell you is that if you are
involved in New Age um they it's it can
be very confusing they they take
scriptures out of context to try to make
it look like the world is one way or God
is something he's not but my appeal to
you is please go back and actually read
the Bible because if you actually take
the time to learn what the book actually
says and not just what the gurus tell
you not just what the witches tell you
in the books you'll see it really is
very different and even if you're not so
sure that the Christian God is the true
God give him a chance just pray ask him
to reveal himself look into his word and
he
will and what you said is so
specific and what I heard is basically
when you go to the Bible First pray
appeal to God from the heart be sincere
and secondly make sure that you go line
upon line that it's precept by precept
line upon line here a little there a
little you don't have to rush but that
same effort that you took to be in
meditation with the Antichrist you could
make that same uh dedicated effort with
God and Jesus and the Holy Spirit and
you can be delivered absolutely the holy
spirit is a teacher to us so just pray
ask to be taught because he will reveal
himself thank you so much Haley as we
come to a close be not dismayed if
perilous practices have become a part of
your life our guests are primary
examples of Christ extending his love
and forgiveness to them you're not alone
so please you can be delivered from Evil
if you found yourself a loved one or an
acquaintance to deceived by a wolf and
sheep's clothing rest assure there is a
way
[Music]
[Applause]
out